Yeah, man. It was not my finest hour,
but I got wrecked by Amazon.
This interview actually happened a while ago when I was just first starting out
to interview for all these bank companies. Oh. And when, I mean Fang, I mean,
Fang, Todd, and I'm not going to say fan group Todd all the time,
so I'm just going to say Fang. So when I say Fang,
think of a big tech companies anyways. Yeah.
So I got an onsite interview.
I went there and then I bombed it.
Amazon.
By the way. Thank you so much audible for spawn. No, I'm just kidding then.
But uh, but I do want you to watch this trailer of my startup series.
Check it out.
So we've got this vision. Can you talk to me a little bit more about that?
Like what is your startup idea? Yeah, it's a
present you not vine.com a platform to share a
6.1 second long looping videos.
It's a website that you can upload and it's a mobile.
What do you think about this are pretty dominant, to be honest,
thinking about scalability on MVP right now are mostly my patients with
George ideas. I am the most qualified person for this job. I get done.
No we can't launch,
but to be honest, I just can't get Ari off my mind.
Who's Aria hate that guy.
So you still working for Microsoft? So what about you?
Where are you up there? I'll make him feel the pain
until he's completely broken.
All right. Back to the Amazon interview.
I just want to tell you guys quickly play by play what exactly happened,
because it might be useful for you guys who want to apply to Amazon.
So I got an Amazon referral from one of my friends and, uh, yeah,
that's actually basically how I applied to jobs nowadays so that I could skip
the line using the referral. So yeah.
Make sure you make friends in college because it's really important after a day
or two. Um, I got a coding assessment.
It was a two coding question challenge and they give you 90 minutes to do it.
And I had to sign some sort of a confidential agreement.
So I can't really share you the questions,
but I could kind of tell you it's basically, uh,
easy slash medium questions and um, yeah, that's it.
There's also a section that is like,
describe your approach where you just write about how you did your question and
what was your approach.
And then there's also a section that's kind of like behavioral. Um, well,
I mean, they call it a survey,
but I think it's actually just a behavioral portion.
So of course I passed it because I've seen the questions already now. Kidding.
Am I? I don't know. I'm kidding. Am I? I don't know. No, I'm good. I'm good.
I didn't see. After I passed a coding assessment, uh,
I actually didn't get a phone interview.
I just talked to the recruiter and they sent me right away for an onsite,
which is kind of interesting. Yeah.
So onto the onsite here is how I up
immediately.
I went to the Amazon office in San Francisco and I went there pretty early.
I think I went there maybe 10 minutes early.
Now you really want to go there early because it's an interview.
You don't want to be late. So it's pretty important.
And also you might want to drink some water,
go to the bathroom right beforehand. So that's pretty important.
So then I went to the lobby and I checked in and then I asked for the person
that needs to come down to get me. I just sat in the lobby,
waiting and waiting and waiting. And, and then,
because I was paranoid, uh, two minutes before the scheduled time interview,
I checked my phone and then I realized,
I asked the wrong person to come to the front desk.
It's okay. It's okay. I fixed it. I went back to the front desk and I fixed it.
No biggie, no problem. I would sat back down five minutes,
go by 10 minutes, go by. And still,
no one was picking me up. I thought they were just late or something.
So check my phone. And I was like, I was in the wrong building.
So I sprinted to the right building and I was already 15 minutes late by then.
And then it took another five minutes to get the first interviewer.
And when he came, he, he asked me, you just, uh,
you just flew here this morning? Nope. Oh, so,
so you flew in yesterday? Yeah. Traffic is pretty bad, right? I mean,
SF is crazy. Uh, no traffic was fine.
Did, uh, did we put you in a hotel that was really far or something?
No. Um, I actually live here, like in the Bay area.
Yeah. And he just stared at me.
He was trying to hide his disappointment and then I just said, yeah,
um, I was in the wrong building. Um, I got kind of confused,
sorry.
So we went into the interview room and he sat me down and he started asking me
about my resume. He started asking me about, you know,
why I wanted to switch back into SWE. And when I was done explaining,
he was like, okay, let me talk about myself a little bit.
Here's what I do at Amazon. It's like, Holy, dude. I don't have time, man.
I'm already 15 minutes late. Just give me the coding question.
I didn't actually say that. But that's what I was thinking.
Like on the exterior, I was more like, Oh, fascinating.
That is quite a difficult problem. How does your team tackle this? Anyways,
he took his sweet time and I ended up only getting like 20 minutes for the
actual coding interview. I mean, I did. Okay. Uh, I got the optimal solution.
I was able to code it up,
but my code had some bugs here and there and I was able to fix it while I was
debugging my code. But you know, I was kind of messy.
I didn't explain my thought process very well because I was,
I was pretty stressed with time. Right.
So I wasn't able to perform like I would have if I had more time,
to be honest though,
I'm not a hundred percent sure that is the reason why they failed me.
It could be theater interviews too, or specifically one other one.
I'll talk about that later. Anyway. So then I had, uh,
four more of those interviews because, uh,
in total they have five interviews, usually it's for coding and one,
uh, system design. Well, at least that's what I had. So yeah,
it's a long day and you get tired by the end of the day,
the four coding questions were mostly easy to mediumly code questions.
So those weren't that bad.
I did decently on them because I practice Lee code and I wouldn't say
I aced them, but I,
I did solve most of the questions optimally, but sometimes I need a hint.
And also sometimes, uh, my code had some bugs in there,
like maybe even typos. So it wasn't flawless.
Also each of these interviews, they actually have a behavioral portion.
The thing about Amazon is that they have something called the 14 leadership
principles and basically what you have to do,
you just have to memorize all of it.
And then when they asked you behavioral questions,
you have to exhibit these principles, exhibit these leadership principles.
So think about your past experiences or, or just make it up, whatever,
I don't care.
And they have to demonstrate those leadership principles. I think I did.
Okay. Because of my silver tongue or actually more like bronze tongue,
maybe like copper, copper tongue, you know what, nevermind.
I don't think I did that well in the behavioral portion,
I can't even say behavioral.
And then I also had one system design interview and I think that's the
interview that I got screwed on because I didn't practice system interviews that
much. So I think that's why I failed.
So I just wanted to share this story with you guys,
because I want you to know that interviewing can be
a game of luck. I mean, I felt for valid reasons,
but there are many times that you will fell an interview and you're going to
feel like. I mean, I felt like,
but it might've just been luck because a few months
later I'd say that I got offers from companies that
I wanted to work for even more. So you never know. I mean,
sometimes it's just a numbers game. It's pretty random.
I want to end this video on this note,
your interview performance says nothing about you.
It says nothing about your worth. It says nothing about your intelligence.
And it says nothing about how good of a software engineer you are.
Heck I got a few good offers from these big tech companies,
but I don't think I'm that great of a software engineer.
I'm just good at interviewing. It doesn't mean anything.
I'm sure many of you are better software engineers than I am,
but it's just that these interviews can really bring you down and make you lose
confidence, man, don't lose confidence in yourself,
especially because of an interview. Keep practicing, keep getting better.
You won't see huge differences overnight getting these three
offers. It's it's a marathon. It's not a sprint. Not going to lie.
When I got that rejection, I was pretty depressed. I told,
I told myself if I can't even get this offer,
how am I going to get the other job offers that I want,
how am I going to switch from data science to sweet? It feels bad at first.
And it feels like it's going to be forever, but it's not in hindsight.
I realized how silly it was for me to think these things,
because now I got, I got my dream job. I'm doing great at it.
And I feel confident and like, I love my teammates. It's great.
Sometimes failures can be blessings in disguise,
so don't dwell on your failures, but use them to grow.
All right. So that's it. And uh, yeah,
don't forget to check out daily interview pool.com.
We send you one coding question per day,
so you can keep practicing and keep yourself accountable. When I was, uh,
studying for all these interviews,
I made sure that I did at least one question a day.
So that's pretty important. It's a marathon. It's not a sprint, but that's it.